it's monday the 8th of november a winter
warning the nhs boss appealing for the
unvaccinated get jabbed with covid
hospital admissions 14 times what they
were this time last year
as we look into winter i think we're
very clear if this is going to be a
difficult winter
and i am here at the department of
health as the health secretary says jabs
and arms are the way to save christmas
and i'm at heathrow where after more
than 600 days of covid closures
transatlantic flights from the uk to the
us will resume
pm pressures mps prepare for an
emergency debate on the sleaze ride
that's rocked the conservative party
lawsuit filed for the deadly concert
where eight people died as more emojis
about the victims
a lovely man and a great father the wife
of a man killed by a shark off the coast
of western australia pays tribute to her
husband
rest in peace paul
he died what he was what he was
enjoyed doing the most
which was exercising
and i'm live in glasgow as the second
week of cop 26 gets underway meanwhile
the mood music from australia isn't
great they say they will continue to
sell coal for as long as the world
continues to buy it
[Music]
good morning everybody there's a warning
this morning from the head of nhs
england that it's facing a winter like
no other with hospital covered emissions
at 14 times the level they were a year
ago the health service is urging
everyone who hasn't yet had a covid
vaccine to take up the offer and is
doubling down on its appeal for people
to get their booster jabs as the
government looks to avoid tightening
restrictions in the run-up to christmas
melena vistalinovich reports
as the nights get colder and we're
mixing indoors more concerns are growing
this may lead to even more infections
and with four and a half million people
still unvaccinated authorities say
getting jabbed is key to avoiding
restrictions this christmas we have had
14 times the number of people in
hospital with kovid
than we saw this time last year and
we've also had a record number of a e
attendances and indeed
a record number of 999 calls so as we
look into winter i think we're very
clear if this is going to be a difficult
winter and the things that we would
encourage people to do is anything that
they can do to protect themselves so
that's the covid vaccine it's the flu
vaccination
in particular
but psyched parveen put off getting her
vaccine because she was pregnant she
died of kovid never meeting the baby
girl she gave birth to while she was in
a ventilator
she planned
so many things
and this disease didn't give her a
chance to
she didn't even know you know
she have a baby girl a boy
[Music]
it's tragedies like this one that
scientists say vaccines can prevent
10 million booster jabs have been given
out so far and the government says it's
vital that people come forward as soon
as they're called so they're protected
ahead of winter
the message is landing with many it's
very simple get vaccinated it's proven
technology crack on with it i would get
the booster to protect myself
my children
and
my parents were elderly
but not all
some experts say this is down to the
lack of clarity about the threat that
kovitz still presents
this is a very confusing public health
messaging from government because on the
one hand
is concerned about the level of covet
infections and and really urging
everyone to have the vaccination but on
the other hand it's telling people that
they can actually mix freely without any
infection control measures
and they can actually mix without face
coverings without physical distancing
with the nhs already under strain
fears are mounting for what this winter
might bring
milena vassalinovic sky news
talking about that in more detail
throughout the course of the day
meantime the international trade
secretary anne maurice rebellion is
joining us now from cop 26 which we'll
talk about in more detail coming up mr
rebellion but first an emergency debate
uh later on today on a sleazy prime
minister and his government how are you
going to start to reassure the public
so the debate this afternoon i'm sure
will
raise concerns uh from many colleagues
about
the issue which was and uh obviously the
leader of the house has identified the
vote last week conflated two issues uh
inappropriately but that uh the key
message was that mps believe that the
process doesn't have a proper appeal
system built into it and i know that
many colleagues will be raising that
this afternoon and i understand that
speaker of the house will also be making
a statement later on to identify how we
can move forward to help solve that
issue so that mps have the same level of
confidence they have a voice of appeal
if they are
charged with
an issue as anyone would in a work
tribunal elsewhere
will the pm be at the debate later
i'm afraid i don't know that
should he be
well these sorts of debates are usually
uh led and you know confronted by
the ministers uh who are doing it i
imagine but i'm afraid i don't know
because i'm up in glasgow uh that jacob
reespog and the leaders team will
probably be covering my question yeah my
question is whether you feel that on
balance he should be given that your
party the government the prime minister
have had an absolute kicking this
weekend and towards the end of last week
as well so my opinion would be that no
he shouldn't be there he will no doubt
as we all do have uh the house of
commons on uh in his office as he's
dealing with many many other issues that
a prime minister only a prime minister
can deal with
and he will get a briefing of the key
issues raised by colleagues from across
the house later and i believe that the
leader and other ministers
will be well placed to take the dispatch
box this afternoon
yeah um okay uh perception's reality of
course and if he's not there people will
um
uh the public will form their own
opinion on why he may or may not be
there they'll also look at the number 10
refurbishment they look at his holiday
in malbaya which apparently was 25 000
pounds worth for a week they'll look at
his holiday in mystique as well
and they'll be wondering about whether
the prime minister is playing fast and
loose with the rules
well the prime minister has uh followed
the appropriate ministerial uh
guidelines and uh registered all those
activities in the case of staying with
his very old friend zach goldsmith
for a well-earned holiday
a few weeks ago he
set out where he was as we all do if we
receive hospitality
from friends or indeed others who are
not close friends and he's done that
yeah he didn't list it appropriately
though we both know that don't we
so the system is there and he's followed
the prison i believe that uh
the ministerial code is considered to be
uh suitably approved so that's good and
i think you know we come back to the
point of uh you know the fact that a
prime minister who has managed an
incredibly challenging time over the
last 18 months uh with incredible
success as you were talking about the
coveted vaccine just now uh and the
importance that we become resilient as a
nation uh to covert he has led the way
on that driven unbelievably hard indeed
nearly died from the disease himself
before a vaccine had been invented so he
wasn't protected which is why to your
earlier point it's so important that
people are getting their vaccinations in
fact i just booked my booster vaccine
yesterday on the line that's now open
for the 7th of december which is the day
after my six-month
moment and i think that's really really
good really effective so i would
recommend everyone who's already been
double jab to get out there and get
their booster booked in but also to make
sure that if you haven't yet had your
first two jabs that you do that because
it will help ease strain on our
incredibly tired doctors and nurses who
are looking after us all and we want as
few people to be turning up in hospital
because they're unvaccinated with kovid
because that is both a terrible terrible
and avoidable problem now but also puts
huge extra strains on our doctors who
have so many uh backlog of cases to look
after us all as well
okay let's go back to where i was
talking about which was tori sleeves how
much does it cost to become a member of
the house of lords these days
so
across all parties people are put
forward uh to
join the house of lords because they
have usually done
enormously good work it could be
scientific experience it could be
business expertise it could be
charitable good works there's all sorts
of reasons why all parties put forward
uh representatives that they wish to
games house lords to bring
their depth of knowledge in their
particular sphere to that upper chamber
and it brings a an amazing mix of people
we see we hear some of their debates
there so erudite deeply thought through
they're a really important chamber
and all parties put forward
excellent people to take on those roles
they could also donate three million
pounds to the party and be a treasurer
has has happened on the last 16
occasions that works as well doesn't it
so um many business people who have
therefore donated to their parties um
lord sugar has won for the labour party
we have some on our side uh do so
because uh they you know they believe in
political activity we have an incredible
system in the uk where we don't ask the
state to fund our political parties and
if we if we didn't have the uh private
donations that come through from donors
large and small in my constituency
people donate you know 25 pounds a year
uh and you know donors who can
provide more uh do more if we didn't do
that the state would have to pay another
taxpayer the tax the taxpayer would be
funding political activity now i think
our uk system is uniquely well placed to
ensure
that
we get this broad stretch you know the
unions fund a great deal of the labour
party's activity again that's from many
many uh small voices and then some large
ones too it's a mix which brings uh a
real depth of voices to our political
parties across the piece
okay but is it right to say yes or no
it's fine that all recent party
treasures all uh the past 16 have all
become lords is that right
um i don't have the city in front of me
but uh uh people in the conservative
party who take on the take on the
challenge uh telly today you didn't read
the article yesterday in the paper no
i'm afraid i haven't read everything
because i'm busy i'm busy setting up for
today's adaptation day here at clock 26
um
but i still had time to read the paper
um these are treasures
yes yes thank you
each of them have donated at least three
million pounds to the party is it
appropriate that if you donate three
million pounds you can buy yourself a
peerage is that the way that we want to
see our house of lords
so people are put forward for periods as
i've saved for all sorts of reasons and
i don't think that someone who happens
to have been a an extremely good
businessman and made a great deal of
money through business activity usually
also an enormous amount of philanthropy
as well those are the sort of people who
are
across our country amazing people of all
political colours that they should be
barred from going to the house of lords
because they have made a lot of money
employed many many thousands of people
run incredible businesses at their own
risk that that somehow is a bar that's
not the case and those who choose to put
themselves forward in political
uh environments as well as their
business and philanthropic ones uh will
go through the process just like anyone
else and we want a rich mix in the house
of lords of voices with experiences
of our country
let's talk about the standards
commissioner apparently given what was
said by quasi-quarten uh last week
amongst other things saying that she can
she should consider her position it's
reported that she's been given police
protection after threats to her life
given what happened last week with owen
patterson that cannot be right can it
well speaking as a woman who has also
had terrible death threats it is
incredibly hard and we have to be very
resilient
these days particularly as women in
public life and it is very hard and it
is always unacceptable that those think
they can push us around
and
threaten us those voices of those people
who are
aggressing aggressing women who are in
public life is totally unacceptable the
police are incredibly supportive and i
hope that obviously catherine has the
support that she needs through this but
this is something that comes at many
women you know we've heard angela rayne
has been
under attack you know for uh you know
whether or not how she speaks her mind
is is uh you know her own choice but it
is always unacceptable for there to be
death threats and following the tragic
ghastly death of
my colleague david damas just a few
weeks ago
we continue to know that we have to be
incredibly resilient
as politicians and people in public life
this is not how we want our country to
be and we need to all work forwards
to
make sure that the commentary is
considered and carefully done and that
we can all do our jobs across the beast
in an in an environment of safety
should catherine stone consider her
position was quasi quoting right
so she isn't independently appointed and
she will continue to her job and i'm no
doubt she will as i say we were talking
earlier uh the speaker of the house uh i
think we'll be making a statement about
considering uh how to mend the way the
committee works that catherine uh runs
and i think that's the conversation that
we need to have because colleagues have
for some time felt that the way uh the
committee works doesn't have all the
relevant uh protections and safeguards
that it should have so uh we will
continue that and i hope that
catherine's situation will be eased and
that those uh aggressive voices will be
removed from her environment
uh so an answer to my question
so i think catherine needs to be allowed
to
get on with her job
okay so she shouldn't consider her
position um should well members of
parliament position there are colleagues
there are colleagues who who step away
from parliament because the threats to
them become untenable i mean the point
is that we should not be in an
environment where
that where that is a difficult
environment and we have to be very
resilient as all of us in public life of
any political color and indeed
but that is that is the reality the
issue is that is the reality because she
didn't like what she was saying that's
my question given that you didn't like
what she was saying you voted against um
her decision and voted in favor of uh
your former colleague owen patterson
i was here
meant as a party as the government uh
collectively my question is given the uh
results that she came back with do you
think she should consider her position
so the process was followed through and
there was a vote in the house there is
as jacob rees-monk said there was an
error in the conflation of the
individual case of earned patterns and
indeed this wider question uh which i
think will be debated at length today
and i think the speaker will be uh
talking to later on about whether the
framework under which uh catherine stone
works at the moment
is correct or whether it also needs a
separate appeals process and that will
be discussed and colleagues in a
cross-party way will determine uh how to
move that forwards under the speaker's
leadership and that is i think very good
news uh catherine stone is is the woman
in charge of working with the with the
tools and the framework that exists at
the moment and absolutely she has had to
be very resilient uh through some of
these challenges for which i feel for
her as a fellow woman who has also had
death threats for entirely uh
unreasonable positions from people whose
anger allows to spill over into violence
should mps have second jobs
so this has been an issue that's kicked
around
for many years and i think
there are you know arguments either way
we have a wonderful
mix of colleagues so my view is my view
is that i think most uh most you do for
instance those who are doctors and
nurses who continue to maintain their
professional credentials and indeed
serve in their original profession i
think the question of whether uh mp's
having jobs that involve lobbying i
think perhaps should be looked at again
but i think across the board i don't
think we should have a removal of the
ability to maintain or have a second job
because it brings a richness to our role
as members of parliament as well as the
work we do day-to-day with our
constituents
you're at cop 26. you want to have a
quick word about that before we let you
go mr valian
thank you yes here at cop206 today it's
the adaptation day
which is one of the really important uh
aspects that uh historic cops haven't
focused on um we've made it a really
central plank of all the work uh we've
been doing as the cop presidency and
we're
going to be announcing an extra 290
million pounds to support uh the least
developed countries and small island
states to help tackle the urgent
challenges that they need to be
resilient and to adapt to the climate
shocks that are coming now even if we
fix the ca2 emissions challenge today
we would see the heightened
climate impacts continuing to affect
those most vulnerable countries for up
to 100 years to come so adaptation to
the changing climate in their own
locally led
communities is critical and this is
something we're going to be discussing
in depth today and hearing from voices
across the world about how they're
adapting and how they're becoming more
resilient uh to the day-to-day
challenges of these climate shocks
good to talk to you thanks so much
indeed for joining us uh today i'm marie
trevelyan thank you
and just a reminder if you want to catch
up on any of our interviews or watch the
program when you are out and about this
morning of course you can you can find
us on the mobile app or go to our
website and go into our live blog to
watch the programme and you can catch up
on the interviews on my twitter as well
if you would like to twitter feed at k
burley
returning to one of our other top
stories and the chief exec of nhs
england has warned that we are facing a
winter like no other with both covid and
flu putting an increased pressure on the
service the health service is appealing
to the unvaccinated to come forward and
be jabbed shingi maruriki is joining us
now hello to you um shingi so there are
people who are still not vaccinated at
all and the national health service is
saying now is the time
morning indeed there are and it's
interesting when you look at the figures
the department of health has said that
30 of over 80s and 40 of over 50s have
yet to come forward for their booster
jabs and now we're moving into hearing a
bit about the language of lockdowns and
restrictions sajid javid the health
secretaries encouraging people to come
forward to get their boosters to help
play their part and also to stop there
being any lockdown restrictions over
christmas and from today the government
is making it easier for people to book
their third jobs in advance why is this
important it's because the waning effect
of the effect of waning immunity is
beginning to be seen we've heard reports
of people who have had two doses of the
jab people who are clinically vulnerable
and elderly now ending up in hospital
six months after having a job some of
those people are dying as well we know
that the winter is about to bite they're
a record nhs waiting list
as well and i think the message from the
government is more people need to get
jabs in their arms as soon as possible
okay
thank you
first time in more than 600 days can you
believe it transatlantic travel has
resumed in an important milestone for
covert
economic recovery fantastic news isn't
it paul kelso at heathrow for us and
it's going to be quite a funky take-off
isn't it paul in a little while
yes it is this is a big day for the
airline industry particularly the
british airline industry in british
airways and virgin atlantic okay they
are sworn rivals they spent most of the
last couple of decades kicking lumps out
of each other well today they are
staging a joint takeoff of two their
first two transatlantic flights to the
us carrying british based passengers as
the u.s border reopened
about two hours ago now this morning
they're going to take off simultaneously
here at heathrow
as they mark the reopening of an
absolutely crucial
route to their businesses they're based
on a huge amount of business and leisure
travel to the united states a ba will
start flying to 17
destinations today and that'll rise into
the mid 20s gives you an idea of just
how important those transatlantic routes
are and they'll be carrying uh mainly in
the first instance it appears people
reuniting with relatives partners loved
ones who they've been unable to see on
any kind of regular basis the us has
not had the uk border open since march
2020 albeit u.s travelers has been able
to fly here since july so there has been
a little bit of contact day but we can
only only imagine what that kind of
almost two-year
gap in being able to visit loved ones
has meant you will still have to go
through the covid hoops you'll need to
be double vaccinated you need to take a
test at least within three days of
departure and another one uh two days
after you arrive in the united states so
there's still some restrictions but a
sign another big sign of return to
normal in international travel and both
the airlines ba and virgin hope they
will see them start to return to the
kind of revenues that have been
decimated
by covid uh with a cost of at least five
thousand jobs for the two airlines we've
talked about okay paul for now thanks so
much indeed and we'll be speaking to the
head of virgin atlantic and a couple of
pilots as well so synchronized takeoffs
on the two runways at heathrow 27l and
27r that's going to be pretty cool isn't
it we'll cover that for you live via the
sky copter later on i know we spoil you
still to come on the programme speaking
to the chair of the house of commons
committee on standards chris bryant
ahead of the emergency debate in
parliament later on
today and i'll get the view of one of
only three conservative members who sits
on the standards committee that's
alberto costa
and then at quarter to wait we'll speak
to the young climate activist who has
been cleaning the beaches of blythe with
her trusted teddy bear
that to come
[Music]
meantime looking at some of the other
stories making news this morning for you
taking you to texas one of the first of
many expected lawsuits has been filed on
behalf of a man injured in the crash at
a travis scott concert in texas
attorneys for manuel souza are suing
scott livenation and others saying they
were responsible investigators are
expected to examine the design of safety
barriers to figure out what went wrong
on friday night
the identities of some of the eight
people who died have started to emerge
two best friends and a teenage student
who loved dancing are among the victims
there just wasn't enough security
telling people to like
you know push like move back because we
were literally just like up against the
rails and could like barely breathe
because literally i was in that like
initial group
like up close to the stage and i
literally was like this the whole time
and i couldn't move so like as soon as
he came out the wave just like kind of
crushed me in
police have called off the search for a
swimmer who was attacked by a shark in
western australia on saturday
paul milichip believed to be originally
from the uk was described as a wonderful
father before he fell victim to the
predators police only managed to turn up
a pair of goggles thought to belong to
mr millership after an extensive marine
search his wife who didn't wish to be
named reportedly thanked nearby
teenagers who helped raise the alarm to
the attack and paid a heartfelt tribute
to her husband
rest in peace paul
he died
what he was what he was
enjoyed doing the most
which was exercising
he was a wonderful man wonderful father
and he loved his exercise we
had been going down to the beach two or
three times a week
we would go running first and then go
swimming and he went for
like he swam for a kilometer
it was due to swim for a kilometer on
saturday um i just went into the water
and out again because it's cold and i'm
not a huge fan of the cold water
a police official in france has been
injured in an attack according to the
country's interior minister
gerald dominin posted a tweet saying the
institute took place in can in the south
of france he said the assailant has been
neutralized and that he'll go to the
scene later on today
a bus has been hijacked and set on fire
in the belfast suburb of newton abbey
police say four masked men got onto the
bus ordered the passengers and the
driver to get off and then torched the
vehicle no injuries have been reported
the defense secretary has said the army
is woefully behind the rest of the
public sector in allowing women to have
careers and it must do better ahead of a
crunch meeting with senior generals ben
wallace told sky news is vital to
creating the right kind of culture
his highly unusual intervention followed
a series of concerning claims involving
the army's handling of allegations of
abuse and harassment
the army has been you know in public
there's some been significant issues
around some of the discipline
processes there's been you know worries
by women serving in the army that we saw
in the evidence they gave to the house
of commons and i'm really determined
that we don't squander the new reforms
in the army by failing to fix and get
right the culture and where we're going
in the future
elon musk's more than 62 million twitter
followers says the tesla chief should
sell 10 of his stake in the electric car
maker the spacex founder had suggested
selling part of his holdings to pay
taxes and ask for his followers to give
their view it comes after a proposal in
the u.s congress to tax billionaires
assets to help pay for joe biden's
social and climate change agenda mr moss
has said that he was prepared to accept
either outcome of the poll
quick look at the weather very quick
look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
forecast is mixed with atlantic rains
spreading south and then lingering for
several days early mist and fog will
clear from southern and eastern parts to
give a bright but chilly chilly start to
the day milder but cloudy in the west
with rain over ireland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we love these pictures don't we these
are the latest coming from the cumbria
vieja volcano on the spanish island of
la palma continuing to spew lava and ash
over the weekend scientists say the
eruption that's alternatively ebbed and
surged since september could last for
around another three months more than 7
000 people have been evacuated from
their homes due to the threat of the
lava
now once a conservative mp the other is
a labour mp but they both sit on the
house of commons committee on standards
speaking to them both after the break
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
coming up in just a second we'll be
speaking to chris brian he's the chair
of the house of commerce committee on
standards
before that though labour demanding
boris johnson apologizes to the nation
over the owen paterson lobbying scandal
ahead of an emergency debate on
parliamentary standards due to take
place later on today the prime minister
has been told he should consider his
position following his aborted effort to
block a common suspension of the former
tory mp i asked the international trade
secretary anne-marie trevelyan whether
second jobs for mps should be
reconsidered
we have a wonderful uh mix of colleagues
so my view is my view is that i think
most
most you do for instance those who are
doctors and nurses who continue to
maintain their professional credentials
and indeed serve in their original
profession i think the question of
whether uh mp's having jobs that involve
lobbying i think perhaps should be
looked at again but i think across the
board i don't think we should have a
removal of the ability to maintain or
have a second job because it brings a
richness to our role as members of
parliament as well as the work we do
day-to-day with our constituents
chris bryant is with us as i said chair
of the house of commons committee on
stance hello thanks for joining us uh on
the programme uh reconsidering whether
mp should have lobbying jobs we already
have a rule on this we've had it since
1695. it says that you can't and lobby
for uh or you can't engage in paid
advocacy in other words you can't lobby
government ministers and officials on
behalf of some of a paying client of
yours that's exactly what owen patterson
was found guilty of he did it not just
once but on 14 occasions he was paying
being paid a hundred and twelve thousand
pounds a year which is more than the
average cost of a house in my
constituency in the ronda
and he pursued the commercial interests
of his paying clients it's very clearly
already forbidden
you can what you could do sorry receive
funds you just can't lobby but you can't
lobby government ministers you can offer
guidance as a second job to um
so if he had been offering guidance to
randox without then trying to put
pressure on government ministers that
would have been fine well and so so this
is i think the grey area which the
committee the there's another committee
the committee on standards in public
life which is completely separate from
parliament and it has recommended for
the last few years that you should have
a rule saying um you can't uh mps can of
course be a gp
or they can serve you know they can help
in accident emergency they can have all
those kind of jobs professional jobs
they can write books they can
write some
they can do broadcasting and things like
that but the one thing that they
shouldn't be able to do is have a job
where they are effectively peddling
access to parliament
and you could argue that any job where
you're a sort of consultant a strategic
consultant on parliamentary affairs is
in the end breaches that rule so um it's
one of the many things that we're
looking at at the moment in this and the
standards committee we're meant to
review the code of conduct every
parliament we didn't do that in the last
parliament because it's so short and
we're very close to producing a new
report on on all of that and i but but
it it does worry me sometimes that i
mean in essence last week
um
it was a terrible terrible reputational
damage that the house did to itself by
voting
to park the issue of whether owen
patterson had behaved inappropriately in
a kind of lay-by
and to try and blow up the whole
standard system just to protect owen
patterson we've got to rescind all of
that we've got to undo that damage and i
hope we can do that tomorrow we know
what the government was trying to do
they got themselves tied in knots but
basically what they were trying to say
was there wasn't an appeals procedure in
place like there would be with an
industrial tribunal for a lay person uh
there is uh an appeals process what
happens is that the commissioner
produces her report when she's she's
independent of everybody but and once
she's decided um that there's been a
breach then she sends that com that
memorandum to our committee we've not
seen anything until that moment we are
we heard owens
appeal both in writing
we published all the documents that he
sent to us including all the witness
statements that he provided and we
listened to him for the best part of two
and a half hours unfortunately i mean
the facts just spoke for themselves um
now
there may be elements of the process
that we could tidy up but i i've spoken
to several
employment lawyers over the weekend and
former high court judges who said
there are very few people would who
would get such a rigorous and fair
process in their ordinary day um in
their ordinary place of employment up
and down the country um of course mps
shouldn't be treated worse than anybody
else but owen really did have
a fair hearing and due process
so you say
certain aspects of the process should be
looked at again like what
um well one of the rules that we've just
referred to maybe we could make that
clearer i'm i'm i'm still a bit shocked
that amaritrevalen didn't understand
that we already have a rule that um
forbids paid lobbying um i think we may
want to look at the relationship between
the commissioner and the committee about
whether um we should give her greater
independence at the same time wanting to
make sure that some of the horrific um
bullying that we've seen over the last
few weeks when people have tried to
bully her into not doing investigations
that that she is properly protected um i
think i want to keep the independence we
might want to say you know at the final
stage
um the there should be and also an
appeal on the sanction there is an
appeal on the facts but maybe there
should be an appeal on the sanction and
who that should be decided by
um
i think we'll lay all of that out in our
report in the next few days and weeks
we're very close to producing a report
and then the house can think about this
in the new year
i don't think we should leap into making
sudden changes we should do that in a
cool calm and collected way and people
have to call off the dogs the government
i mean one of my fundamental principles
is government shouldn't
i mean it should steer clear of
independent disciplinary processes
because otherwise
you know it felt last week as if we were
all walked into the quagmire by the
government and lots of tory mps are very
fed up and i'm fed up about it too uh
crazy cartoon told me on the program
that um
the chair the uh commissioner should
consider her position do you think she
should no she should stay um she's done
a magnificent job she is uh resilient
which is just as well because honestly
the attempts to lobby members of the
committee which insult which itself is a
a a breach of the rules and which can
lead to a suspension um the attempts to
bully her the all the briefing against
her in the press i'm told that some
whatsapp groups i mean they're just full
of libelous comments about her um
i you know
mps set the system up only two and a
half years ago
only two and a half years ago andrea
ledson was the person who tabled it in
the house of commons and i think we need
to stick with that system we have a
committee the standards committee which
will produce a report on some possible
changes in the next few weeks and then
everybody can consider them in the
calmness of the new year who was who was
lobbying the uh committee
well quite a lot of members i don't
really want to inflame that issue i've
um but there have been a couple of
occasions with an allegation though
isn't it
yes it is and i'm not laying it in again
i'm not okay
much as i love you i'm not going to um
have a go at individuals i want us to
get to a place where everybody
understands you can't lobby members of
the committee um i had to say to a
couple i had to say
because i'm not aware of i hear younger
members of the committee were being
bullied to decide against paterson
um
i've been told
uh i don't know about that not about
members of the committee i don't know
but but i'm certain that it's been a
very stressful time for all the members
of the committee um over the last few
weeks because it's been very high
profile i think the campaign that was
waged in the telegraph and by some of
owen's friends was um well i think it
was mark harper the former government um
conservative chief whip who said that it
was the most unedifying um thing he'd
seen
normally a committee report especially
when it's as categorical as ours is
simply goes through the house without
emotion
without a vote or a division
i think it was utterly inappropriate
what the government did last week so is
that you can rescue this okay chair of
the committee you would not tolerate any
member of the committee being bullied
for a start we have a very clear
guidelines on bullying if anybody has
been bullied that should be reported to
the in through the icgs system for
sexual harassment and bullying in
parliament that isn't dealt with by our
committee it's dealt with by um
the independent expert panel which is
chaired by stephen irwin and i'm
absolutely sure that he would take all
any allegations of that kind very very
seriously um the prime minister is
likely not to be at this uh emergency um
discussion later on today emergency
debate i spoke to anne-marie travelling
she said that's fine what do you think
actually i'd prefer him to stick away
from all of these issues um
i
he shouldn't have been in the chamber to
talk about it last week he shouldn't
have been um you know marching his
troops up to the top of the hill to vote
um down or vote for that most bizarre
motion i mean
when you think about it
the strangest part of the motion that
the prime minister wanted everybody to
vote for last week was that it was
changing
due process at the very last point in
that process for a named individual
that is not the way you provide justice
for anybody it's the polar opposite of
justice is what
victor orban would do in hungary it's
not what we do in britain
as far as his two holidays are concerned
mystique and marbella and of course
wallpapergate um does he still have
questions to answer there
well on mustique we've already we did a
report
and i think even the prime minister
would accept that he had a fair hearing
office um we did have some criticisms of
the way he
uh sort of dragged the process out and
kept on being unable to provide answers
to some of the questions that the
commissioner had asked um or i i'm not
going to comment on any other case that
might or might not occur because
we do have a genuinely independent
process which is that first of all the
commissioner if she thinks it's right
investigates um i think she's already
said in relation to the um redecoration
of downing street that she's going to
wait until such time as the electoral
commission and finished their work um to
decide whether or whether or not to
start an investigation but she's
independent i'm not going to tell her
whether she should or shouldn't engage
in anything to do with that and i'm not
going to comment on it and apparently
your leader has suggested that the prime
minister should consider his position
well look i mean i'm a labour mp i'm not
an enormous fan of the prime minister um
big step though to say consider his
position don't often hear words like
that from the opposition i'm i'm here as
chair of the standards committee i'm i'm
not going to be waving any um kind of uh
party banner this morning um
i i see
the thing is i as you know i i think
okay i i care passionately about
parliament um i i'm going later on this
morning to a conference about acquired
brain injury something i've been banging
on about for ages and concussion and
sport and so on um i've got a private
members move i want to get through in
three weeks time on the third of
december which would i think help people
and
i can only do that if people have trust
in parliament in parliamentary democracy
we are all there because we want to
change the world well there's the danger
of course that if government repeatedly
tries to defend somebody for what is a
corrupt practice
then of course the danger is that people
will lose confidence not just in one
party but in the whole of politics so
that's why i i
i take my job as chair of the of the
standards committee really really
seriously we're very well served by a
very good commissioner we've got seven
magnificent lay members who come
completely different backgrounds um it's
quite a lot of them have been involved
in in similar bodies in other
professions and seven members and i and
the seven elected members don't always
agree but we did on this on owen
patterson we were absolutely categorical
he had broken the rules not just once
but on 14 occasions and um it really it
genuinely saddened me last week that the
government got this so completely and
utterly wrong chris brian thank you very
much indeed for joining us
thank you
and the sleaze drive features on many of
the morning's front pages as well of
course uh let's start with the eye
the pm battles to contain tori sleeves
backlash as boris johnson prepares to
face parliament over the handling of the
owen paterson scandal is how they see it
the metro also focuses on conservative
mps joining the growing backlash against
mr johnson despite one senior minister
dismissing the row over sleeves as a
storm in a tea cup
the deli murray seized police under
pressure to propose uh proba forgive me
a cash for honours scandal over peerages
for tory party
donors let's hear from another member of
the committee one of the three
conservative mps on the standards
committee and that's alberto costa hello
to you mr costa thank you for joining us
on the program you just heard some of
the thoughts of your chairman do you
broadly agree with what he had to say
broadly the standards committee works on
the basis wherever possible of unanimity
but chris and i have been discussing for
almost two years
and i was a member of the committee
before chris
the changes that would benefit those
that complain against mps as well as mps
themselves i think what's really
important to outline is that the
committee and standards is currently
constituted as a committee of 14 people
i don't know of any other disciplinary
group as large as that but i think where
the changes need to be made
is that the commissioner
is the investigator of cases and the
presenter of cases to mean my colleagues
but then she attends the committee
wearing a different hat as the principal
adviser to the committee and i think
that puts the commissioner in an
unenviable position that she has to have
these two conflicting hats the problem
lies with the house of commons on rules
known as standing orders and i've argued
with chris over many months now that the
rules need to be changed in order to
ensure that we have a much better system
and the second and final thing i'd say
is this
we've already brought into the house of
commons former high court judges
i'm quite happy to relinquish my role as
an adjudicator in these matters i don't
think mps should be adjudicating on
disciplinary matters involving other mps
i think we should bring in the judiciary
as we've done for bullying and sexual
harassment claims and make sure that the
committee and standards with laypeople
retains a role as the drafting body of
the code of conduct and the associated
rules but let the commissioner present
her case to judges and let judges be the
ultimate arbiters of this issue
are you suggesting that potentially that
had been the case there may have been a
different conclusion with the case of
owen patterson
well i'm not going to get into that
particular case but what i will say is
that i've been passionately arguing for
change up until very recently i was the
only lawyer on that committee a
committee of 14 people was the only
lawyer that was able to see as a member
of that committee that in the outside
world usually with disciplinary groups
you have panels of three people but k if
any of your viewers were being
disciplined at work they would be given
the right to appear before the committee
or make representations to the committee
a hr manager might make representations
but what the hr manager would not
necessarily be is then going to advise
the very panel that she's just been
making representations to and if you do
have a system like that and work the
ultimate
arena to resolve these issues is a court
of law we don't have that in the house
of commons and that's why the standards
committee
must change it has to improve to ensure
that we've got a much more transparent
system where we adopt as close as
possible
uh rules and practices processes and
appeal system which is closely as
possible mirrors a court of law and
that's why i think it's high time now
that i'm listened chris listens to me
and that we bring in judges as we've
done for the independent experts panel
as you say you've been having this
negotiation this discussion for months
one wonders why it was conflated in the
way that it was last week
well the government were right to regret
the conflation of the two issues but
look my role as one of the more senior
mp members of the standards committee
and the only lawyer until recently on
that committee is to make sure that the
committee members understand that in the
real world there are norms of appeal
processes there are rules of evidence
that tell you who you can and cannot
bring before you and i do want to remove
that unenviable position that the
commissioner is in i want to support the
commissioner by making the rules much
clearer that she should remain the
investigator and the presenter of cases
but she should not have the conflicting
role of then going on to advise the very
committee that's considering her own
report i don't think that's fair on the
commissioner i don't think that's fair
in the committee and i certainly don't
think that's fair on those that complain
or indeed the mps that receive the
complaints but it's time that we bring
in former high court judges as we've
done for the independent experts panel
which hears bullying and sexual
harassment claims to ensure that mps are
no longer involved in the direct
adjudication of these matters that's the
fair way to do that that's the way that
i would expect the house of commons to
go forward and i'm quite confident that
in a few months time that in fact will
be the system as we go forward
you talked about bullying um there there
are allegations that younger members of
the committee were bullied into making
the decisions that they made and the
chairman who i spoke to a moment ago
said he wasn't aware of that in any way
shape or form were you
now i can't say that any member of the
committee has come to me and said that
they've been bullied into making any
decision look it was a unanimous report
we all stand by that report and this
isn't about questioning the veracity of
that report what this is about is my
primary duty as a member of the
standards committee under the rules is
to oversee the work of the commissioner
and it's important that members of the
committee both mps and lay people are
able to do that job without fear or
favor in ensuring that we scrutinize the
work of the commissioner and wherever
possible if the commissioner has done a
good job we uphold the commissioner's
finding but what we can do is enhance
the process ameliorate the process and
make sure that we've got proper rules of
process and a proper appeal system that
currently is not there and that's why
i've been passionately arguing for
almost two years that we need to change
the rules and make it much more
transparent and remove mps from the
process bring in former members of the
judiciary and make it a system that
members of the public have full trust in
good to talk to you thank you for
joining us on the program we appreciate
it thank you
second week of cop 26 hasn't gone off to
the best of starts australia's resource
minister keith pitt has pledged to
continue selling coal as long as there's
demand for it
time now to meet the uh incredible
eight-year-old girl who's been picking
up litter on beaches every day since she
was three ray of faye waddle has managed
to collect a staggering 400 000 plastic
bottles for the past five years with her
trusty teddy bear at her side hello to
you both
hi
what's the teddy bear called
fabric
cranberry pie pie cranberry pie great
name um hello dubo thank you for joining
us tell me mom uh tracy how you both
first got involved with picking up
litter
um yes rhea was a very small child and
she first noticed um polar bears
fighting with her bin lainer and
svalbard when she was very young in the
newspaper and she asked the question how
did that bin laina get there and that's
when it began and she didn't want them
fighting with the plastic because it
wasn't food and that was when she was
about three years old
good girl
um so raya then what do you do you i
mean 400 000 bottles that's so many i
don't know how you managed to count them
all what do you do you go down to the
beach or you go down to the local park
and pick them all up
i go everywhere
do you
good for you and then what do you do
with them
bring them to the tip
do you good girl
um does she go out in all weathers tracy
every single day we're out 365 days a
year even when it's raining blown a
hooli asha calls it with cranberry and
she's out every day even christmas day
and she's checking that the marine
animals are safe
and do people i mean obviously she must
be a bit of a celebrity locally now in
bligh do people help
um yes ryan's got 12 bins now
and do you want to talk about your
things real yeah
what's your bins called
she has a flip-flop that will be in
and it reminds people not to forget
their flip-flops during the summer times
and one little bin saved 15 000 items
this summer
everyone along the shorelines helped in
any plastic the founder popped it into
our bin and we took it to the tip
and raya tell me
about um other people at school do they
come and help you sometimes as well
no
reason
she's taught at home and then we'll go
out every single day and do our
environment work outside
so anyone that's seen
fired by her and their copy
and ray what do you want to do when you
when you've um finish homeschooling when
you're a bit bigger what do you want to
do then
[Music]
okay what you want to do be a big one
for marine biologists
oh
a midwife or a marine biologist aiming
high there mom
yes
she's studying medicine as well so she's
very interested in the safety of the
marine animals and the sea birds and all
the way life as well
fantastic and tracy you must be so proud
of her
i'm really proud of ria as our daddies
and our brothers and she really is
savior of the sea she calls the wildlife
parks the wildlife's living room that
we're invited into
and really the human behavior is
affecting all the wildlife all the
marine animals and rhea wants to stop
this from happening and she's got a
potion from the ocean there
and with 50 pieces in and she asked
people would you drink this and
obviously the answer is no but the
marine animals don't have a voice they
can't say no they don't want to drink
that talk to both of you we've got to
leave it there back to school
see you soon thanks a lot